my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
university comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy so in this video
we're going to talk about palmitate
synthesis and the actual reactions of it
before we can actually have the
reactions occur though we need to have
what's called the priming of
acetylcholine melanie Ocoee which is
essentially the attaching of acetyl co a
and melanie Ocoee each to the acyl
carrier protein of the fatty acid
synthase complex if you recall the SE
the acyl carrier protein of the fatty
acid synthase what it does is it carries
the substrates from catalytic site to
the catalytic site and to the next one
to the next one but so before that can
happen when you actually attach the
substrates to the actual acp so that
that can happen so the two that we're
going to do that with our acetyl co a
and Melanie okay so both of them have
the coenzyme a is attached via thio
ester linkages so all we're going to do
is replace that bio ester linkage to
acetyl co a with a thioester linkage to
the acyl carrier protein that's really
all that's happening here we're taking
an acetyl co a and turning it into a c2
acp which just frees up the coenzyme a
and now we have the acetyl group
attached to the acyl carrier protein so
that that reaction is catalyzed by
acetyl translation lays why is it called
that well because it moves this acyl
group specifically the acetyl group of
acetyl co a over to the acyl carrier
protein same exact thing happens with
Melanie okay we're just moving the
Millenial portion to the acp and that's
catalyzed by millennial trans acyl ace
before in the fatty acid synthase video
this was called a tea and this was
called MT and you'll see the the rest of
the enzymes later I might not mention
them as by their abbreviations but you
should be able to recognize it if you
paid attention to the other videos and
pays out here so once we have the acetyl
ACP and the melanie OACP we basically
have the acetyl group in the melanie
root both attached to the acyl carrier
protein
so we have our substrates that are
attached so these two are now primed
they are prime they are ready for fatty
acid synthesis now just as a side note
this doesn't have to occur with acetyl
co and Melanie Ocoee for odd-numbered
fatty acids what can happen is instead
we get it instead of instead of acetyl
co a we have propane yoko a which is a
three carbon molecule you'll remember
propane yoko a from-from the beta
oxidation of odd-numbered fatty acids so
basically what we're trying to say here
is that if if we had started with a
propane yoko a and a melon yoko a
instead of an acetyl co a and a Malin
Yoko a we'd get a pro Peniel acp and a
malonyl acp and we have the condensation
reaction we have a three carbon molecule
joining with a two carbon molecule to
make a five carbon molecule that we'd
start with as opposed to what we're
going to get here which is we're going
to get a four carbon molecule that would
start with so this is broad number of
fatty acids just as a side note we're
not going to worry about that too much
in this video okay cool on to the
reactions the actual four steps and
again I call it beta reduction and
hopefully that'll make sense to you as
we go through this okay so we've got
acetyl ACP malonyl acp and they're ready
to go they're primed now they can
undergo the four steps the actual beta
reduction steps so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to connect
this acetyl group this acyl portion
specifically the acetyl group to this
portion of Melanie Laci P to get acetyl
a so ACP and this carboxyl group here on
Melanie Ocoee leaves as a carbon dioxide
okay so this is the condensation
reaction because we're forming a
carbon-carbon bond between this portion
right here right and this portion right
here
the aceo portion so the carbon-carbon
bond that we make this condensation is
right here that's the bond that we made
right there okay that's the
carbon-carbon bond
that we formed that's the condensation
reaction so now we've got a four carbon
molecule called Osito Osito acp this
reaction is catalyzed by acyl malonyl
acp because what it does is it takes an
acyl group which the acyl malonyl acp
condensing enzyme also called keto a so
synthase so this was called this was the
C II in in the previous video so we why
is it called this acyl malonyl acp
condensing enzyme well it takes the acyl
group from from here right and it takes
the Millenial acp group and condenses
them to form this molecule this molecule
is a key to a skeeto a so synthase
specifically it's a beta keto a so
synthase because at this beta carbon we
have a ketone so this this acetyl a so a
CP is a beta key to a subgroup a beta
keto acyl acp because it's still
attached to this acp so now this is
going to be taken to the next site where
the next reaction happens or the first
reduction happens all right so this
first reduction of this Osito Osito acp
this four carbon molecule here this for
carbon beta keto a so acp is going to be
turned into this Delta this D beta
hydroxy beauty relay CP via the first
reduction reaction so we're going to
require the reducing agent NADPH that's
going to go to nadp+ and this reaction
is catalyzed by beta keto acyl acp
reductase why is it called that well
we've got a beta key to acyl ACP right
here as our reactant and it's going to
be reduced right so reductase reductase
it's acting on the beta keto acyl acp
and we get this D beta hydroxy butyrate
a CP I didn't actually put like the
wedges and dashes here to indicate D
that's just because I'm lazy I have
sighs if that's not good for you but the
point is that this is the the D form of
this hydroxy a civil ACP
so that's the first reduction reaction
then then we've got the dehydration
reaction so we're going to lose water in
this next step so we're going to lose
and actually before I go back I
specifically should probably mention
this is that this beta this beta carbon
goes from being a carbonyl right a
ketone to an alcohol right so that's the
actual reduction there the beta carbon
was reduced
hence beta reduction sorry I didn't
mention that before anyway now we're
going to have the dehydration reactions
we're to lose water we're going to lose
this o H and one of these H's as water
and to get this enol acp so this
reaction is catalyzed by beta hydroxy
acyl acp dehydratase dehydratase makes
sense losing water dehydration it's
acting on beta hydroxy ASO AC P at this
beta carbon we have a hydroxyl group and
the rest is the acyl acp so it's acting
on this to give us this enol
acp okay so now we have this in oil
group and we're gonna have our final
reaction of the round which is going to
be the second reduction so second
reduction means we're going to need a
reducing agent NADPH it's going to go to
nadp+ and this is acting on this email
KO a to give us this beauty relay CP
this is catalyzed by NAACP reductase
well it's a reductase hence the
reduction reaction and we're
specifically reducing the beta the beta
carbon here oh really this is this
molecule but specifically the beta and
this is acting on the Ino a CP this is
an Ian oil a CP so we're reducing this
and that gives us this beauty role a CP
which is essentially an acyl acp
so notice what is this this is just ch3
ch2
ch2 and then this this group here so
this is an acyl group attached to this
acp specifically it's four carbons so
it's beauty relay CP but this is
essentially a four carbon fatty acid
right this is a four carbon fatty acid
that's just attached to the ACP group so
um what I'm going to do with this one
now this acyl group this acyl group here
is going to be attached to the next
Melanie okay a right this Melanie Ocoee
or the value of ACP excuse me
and again this this carboxyl group will
leave as a carbon dioxide and we're
going to join these to connect them and
we'll get this part coming from the
Melanie Ocoee or the Melanie OACP mess
that up again sorry
and this part here this the rest of this
coming this the other four carbons are
coming from from the Beauty relay CP
they soak away so this is a Sol malonyl
acp condensing enzyme allowing this to
happen
so now we have a six carbon keto acyl
ACP so now the reactions repeat right
before the four reaction because of the
condensation the first reduction
dehydration second reduction all those
occur and act for that second round will
have a six carbon fatty acid attached to
the ACP in this case would be hexon io a
CP so these four steps these four
reactions right these the condensation
the first reduction the dehydration and
the second reduction those four steps
will continually repeat each time
needing another new millennial acp and
that will repeat until we get the 16
carbons for palmitate but after we get
the the sixteen carbon a sole acp what
happens well it needs to be released
right so the thigh OS to race on domain
number three of fatty acid synthase it
Cleaves a bio ester linkage writes a
thioester linkage because the that's
this linkage here right that linkage
there it'll cleave that linkage that's
holding the palmitate to the the acp so
once it Cleaves that linkage palmitate
will be free and it'll be just floating
around in the cytosol and probably
be taken to produce some fats hope that
video is helpful thank you for watching